my name is michael schneider i grew up
in rural pennsylvania of all places and
went to college at the University of
Rochester
I moved the Stanford five years ago to
chair the genetics department and start
the new center for genomics and
personalized medicine and the mission of
that is really to try and bring genomics
technology to cure human disease and
better understand them and try and
actually the ultimate goal is really to
bring genomics into everyday human
health and ideally prevent human disease
I really think there's so much we can
learn about genetics and we're in an
incredible period of revolution you can
now sequence human genomes for the first
time we're part of that we're developing
a lot of technologies for sequencing the
DNA of people but it's even more than
that we can actually understand the
activity of the different genes who can
apply this information to better on
their stand human health and disease and
really the ultimate goal I think the way
we do medicine is very Byzantine I think
we should be much more precise in the
way we give drugs to people and give
them at the right time but more than
that I actually think we have to shift
medicine from treating symptoms that's
actually predicting and preventing
genetics and genomics is incredibly
powerful for that from a human genome
sequence we can try and predict human
disease and then prevent it take action
before the disease occurs and that's
just a much better way to deal with the
whole system
you